we're gonna look at some of the
off-season storylines now we've already
talked about desean watson so let's take
him off the table that's an off-season
story line that's already hovered over
the off-season for
the teams that didn't make it to the
playoffs this year it was 18 for the
first time ever so he's off the board
the first storyline that i'm interested
in shireen
and that i will be paying close
attention to and it has ramped up
dramatically over the past couple of
days is russell wilson's future with the
seahawks i don't believe they will trade
him this year but i do believe this is
the year that they have got to prove to
him that they're going to let him be
involved with personnel that they're
going to let the offense run through him
he's no longer an accessory or a
a passive participant he's the offense
just like it is in kansas city with
patrick mahomes and if those changes are
made then it can be salvaged if not
then i think come next year we will be
in a position where russell wilson is
looking elsewhere and quite likely being
trading also traded elsewhere i'll say
this though here's the caveat
june 2nd
because
trading russell wilson before june 2nd
results in a 30 million dollar cap 39
million cap charge for the seahawks
after that it would be 13 this year 26
next year and when you consider there's
most likely not going to be an off
season program
what does it matter you don't need to
have the deal done
march 17 the deal can wait until june 2
especially since there's no way to do
the deal before
june 2 from the seahawks perspective so
i won't be surprised if it happens after
the dust settles on the off-season after
we see free agency after we see the
draft that could be when russell wilson
goes in and says i gave you a chance he
didn't do it i want out on june 2nd so
i've got that little that little slice
that little sliver that little crevice
in the door where i think there's still
a chance that russell wilson could be
gone by the time we get to june 2nd
i think he's there this year mike and i
agree with you he's going to give them a
chance to see what they can do but this
thing is spiraling out of control
quickly when you go back and you look at
what brandon marshall said yesterday
that he thinks that russell wilson is
trying to find a classy way to get out
of town
i think this is headed toward a divorce
at some point i think it's probably a
year away the only thing i think that
keeps russell wilson in seattle long
term is another super bowl just getting
to the super bowl i mean we know he
wanted a second year 2013 2014 they
should have won it and since then three
and five in the po
a lot of it is not russell
and the other side of it too is he's
going to continue to want to get market
value contracts he's had two of them his
current deal lasts for three more years
and i think by next year his agent will
be
basically issuing the ultimatum we want
the market value contract or we want
this to end now and i also think there's
a chance
that the seahawks aren't real happy
about what's gone on over the past few
days and they may decide this is just
untenable this is no longer something
that's going to work we're not going to
give him say over personnel we're not
going to turn the team upside down
we don't want to do this that could
accelerate his departure from seattle
all right we have shireen back i believe
i'm going to tee up shireen for her
first storyline for the 2021 offseason
well mike we saw the picture and you
wrote about it of jerry jones going into
the prosper convenience store to buy a
bottle of wine initially i thought hey
is he going to celebrate maybe with that
prescott who lives in prosper but it
turns out that it was a champagne it was
just in a bottle of wine so we're
assuming that that didn't happen but
it's the back drama and what are the
cowboys going to do i mean they've had
almost two years mike to get this guy
signed to a long-term deal they still
haven't done it and if you get to the
draft and you've applied the franchise
tag to him which is over 37 million
dollars i think you have to consider
using your first round draft pick that's
10th overall to draft a quarterback i
just think you have to think about it
because you don't know if you're going
to have this guy long term and i think
this is going to be a storyline that's
going to play out over the next few
months it's not going to get settled
anytime soon
37 million plus for this year
plus the reality that next year it will
be a 44 bump over the 37 million if they
want to tag him a third time that's over
53 million dollars for 2022 if they
choose to do that and dak prescott has
always pushed his leverage he's always
played this business angle this is part
of the
revolution at the quarterback position
kirk cousins started it dak prescott's
continuing it through action russell
wilson getting involved through words
tom brady one of the big movers of the
needle going from new england to a place
where they basically gave him the keys
to the car it's or the boat as the case
may be it's uh it's it's fascinating and
one one quick thing on on jerry jones
and his wine purchase
i often wonder how different life would
be if you had multiple billions of
dollars and at last check he's worth
eight and a half billion
it's kind of depressing to know you
still go into a gas station to buy your
wine and it's kind of alarming shireen
now maybe the security guy was the one
who took the camera it's alarming to see
someone with that kind of money without
someone nearby
to make sure that something doesn't
happen
to the guy with that kind of money who
would be a target for all sorts of
potential misconduct
i am betting roosevelt wasn't far behind
his long-term bodyguard he's usually
around there and you can usually find
him so i'm betting him somewhere around
there mike
wait why doesn't roosevelt go in to buy
the wine exactly
yeah exactly i'm with you ryan roosevelt
buying the line
you know maybe maybe jerry just had to
pee i don't know i'm trying to i'm
trying to understand
why the guy was in a 7-eleven carrying
two bottles of wine that go for at least
the one in his right hand goes for about
20 bucks and it was a 7-eleven i can't
imagine that the other bottle was
anything that you know was 100 or more
but hey life is a billionaire apparently
not all that much different than than
the life the rest of us lead all right
i'm looking forward to seeing what the
packers do and this is a broad
observation because they're going to
have options in free agency what are
they going to do to upgrade the team
with guys who may want to come play with
aaron rodgers what are they going to do
with the guys they currently have will
aaron jones be back what are they going
to do with their draft picks what are
they going to do about receivers what
are they gonna do with jordan love could
they trade him after one year could he
become a guy who gets caught up in this
quarterback carousel you can't rule out
anything at this point but with the
things that aaron rodgers said
immediately after the nfc championship
game with the way the packers
traditionally operate which is you are
just an employee we'll take care of
finding the players we'll take care of
running the team
fascinating to see if the packers make a
change in an effort to go all in
one time
get that second super bowl for aaron
rodgers or whether they will continue
their attitude of we're going to run the
team as we see fit and if you don't like
it too bad you're under contract shireen
i think the one thing you can count on
is a packers not to use their first
round draft pick on a quarterback this
year can you imagine how what what would
happen in green bay if they did that i
think it would explode probably but
they've got a lot of questions mike and
you know they've been on the cusp for
the last two years and can't get over
that hump they've got to do something to
help aaron rodgers who frankly the
window is is closing a little bit on his
chance to win a second championship and
we all thought brett favre would get
more than one he didn't and here aaron
rodgers sits with one more mvp awards
than he has super bowl championships so
he's ready to win another one and the
packers need to help him do that
a lot of quarterbacks out there trying
desperately to get to two most
prominently russell wilson aaron rodgers
and patrick mahomes a complicating
factor mike patton the packers defensive
coordinator through that game from 16
days ago 17 days now will join the bears
as a senior defensive assistant he knows
a thing or two about what aaron rodgers
can and can't do that makes those two
games even more interesting than they
would be all right next up shireen what
are you looking forward to this off
season
well mike let's go back to week nine
right the saints demolished the
buccaneers 38-3 and we were talking
about the saints and super bowl
favorites oh my gosh how have things
changed since then the saints as
division champions now are in a rebuild
and they're chasing the box frankly they
won the division yet we feel like
they're chasing the bucks who got the
super bowl title and and they're in the
worst cap situation of any team in
football right now if it's 180 million
they're almost 75 million over the cap
we know they can manipulate that but
they have 60 players under contract
they're going to have to move on with
some of those guys what is drew brees
dude that saints resigned jameis winston
did sean payton see enough of taysom
hill in in the four games that he
started to have faith that he is their
quarterback of the future a lot of
questions for this team and he's
starting obviously with with drew brees
and what he's going to do which i think
we all expect him to retire so then the
question becomes who replaces them at
quarterback
one of the most overlooked nuggets of
super bowl week and there's so much that
happens and it's hard to keep up with
all of it when drew brees voluntarily
and unilaterally reduces his salary from
25 million down to the minimum with no
quid pro quo
no
no bonus right that was
clearly and simply an effort to allow
his retirement to be processed after
june 1 reducing the salary cap hit this
year
and reducing dramatically the cap number
they have to carry until june 1 by
dropping his salary by 24 million
dollars and it makes it much easier for
the saints to go out and put a team
around whoever the quarterback will be
whether it's taysom hill whether it's
jameis winston whether it's someone else
last one for me the broader impact of a
potentially reduced salary cap on the
nfl's team specifically the teams that
are in cap trouble and before you can
sit down with the nfl pa and negotiate
what the cap will be and that
negotiation happens every single year
it's the product of back and forth
between the league in the union as to
what the proper numbers should be team
by team spending limit
this year before you get to the point
where you negotiate with the union the
teams have to get on the same page some
teams want it higher some teams want it
lower and that's one of the reasons why
it's going to take some time to get to
the point where they even are ready to
go to the table with the nflpa and an
item that i noticed earlier today from
jabari young of cnbc
he reports that the league wants to have
deals in place not necessarily buttoned
up and signed but deals in place with
the networks for the next wave of tv
contracts that tells me if they get the
kind of money they're looking for then
it becomes easier to move money around
and maybe pump up the salary cap for
this year
and basically borrow from revenue in
future years to make it high enough so
there isn't this chaos when it comes to
free agency and you've got veteran
players who get squeezed out they don't
make much much money teams end up
falling apart potentially or relying
upon really young players it's going to
be fascinating to see how all those
pieces fit together over the course of
the next six weeks shireen
yeah and mike we talk about the 17th
week of the season too they've kind of
sort of committed to that but are we
going to see that 17th week this season
are we going to see fans in the stands
are we going to see full stadiums all
those things are going to play
into how this cap ends up looking
and i think and i think we're going to
see 17 games i think they want the union
to say hey you know what we used to
complain about 17 games
we think we would like one now because
it helps us make back the money all
right what's your last one shireen my
last one is the 49ers are they going to
look to upgrade on jimmy garoppolo we
know last year they looked at tom brady
and the way things turned out mike that
they didn't go that direction the
question for jimmy g is can he stay
healthy i mean we just haven't seen it
over the last three years 2018 he played
three games he played all 16 in 2019
when they go to the super bowl and then
last year he comes back and he plays six
games he also was hurt in new england so
i think you have to take that into
account so what do they do at
quarterback at minimum mike i see them
going out and getting a veteran
quarterback to come in and back him up
yeah look i think jimmy garoppolo is
going to be gone i think they're looking
at all options the cap hit is minimal
2.4 million from moving on from him i
could see him land with the new england
patriots and you know i've mentioned a
couple of times that the 49ers did look
at tom brady tom brady wanted to play
for the 49ers they evaluated the
situation and they said no and the
knee-jerk reaction from a lot of fans is
well that doesn't mean the 49ers would
have won the super bowl no it doesn't
but it also means the buccaneers
wouldn't have won it if anything it
means the chiefs would have completed
the repeat by beating whoever it was
that would have
risen to the top of the nfc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports